joining me now is Dr mehmed Oz
Republican candidate for the U.S Senate
in Pennsylvania Dr Oz
who is this guy John Federman because it
this this story keeps getting more
fanciful by the day
well fetterman's a fraud I'm actually in
Pittsburgh now which is close to where
he's currently living although he's not
from here originally and they know it
and they tell me all the time how much
they dislike him he was supported by his
parents until he was elected as
lieutenant governor four years ago he
lived on handouts without paying his
taxes correctly by the way and yet he's
raising taxes right now advocating for
that on the working class after pushing
for a reckless spending programs and you
know creating all this inflation and
he's a rubber stamp for Joe Biden and
here's the thing he's the most radical
Democratic candidate in a contested
election this cycle I'll say it again
the most radical in a contested election
yet no one knows it and by the way if
you want to go to doctoroz.com and help
me get the word out it will be helpful
because he stored up so much money that
he's been telling that tale that you
just showed I on the other hand I'm the
son of an immigrant I believe in the
American dream because I lived it myself
I respect the needs of workers hurt by
regulations and overreaching government
and the reality is John fetterman
believes in big government and Bloated
bureaucracies that's his life experience
because he's never had to actually work
to make his own money because it was
given to him I believe in the people of
Pennsylvania and if you believe in the
people in individualism and what you do
if you work for yourself which is what
the American dream was about that's the
deal you work hard you succeed you do
the right thing you achieve things that
unimaginable anywhere else on the planet
if you believe that come to doctoroz.com
and share your thoughts because that's
the story we're going to tell as we win
in November
oh Dr Oz you know they've been spinning
this Tail as I said and it's always you
know the kind of the stunts in the
costume so he has the costume he kind of
looks like on Uncle Fester hits the gym
you know that's kind of what it looks
like well you know God bless him I'm
glad he's well he's doing better and so
forth but they you know they put Snooki
out there to say you don't live in
Pennsylvania but are you living in the
house that you and your wife were
married in I think I read that somewhere
is is that the case
it is the case 37 years ago best
decision I ever made I was in medical
school in Philadelphia at Penn I also
went to Wharton business school because
I was studying Healthcare Finance might
come in handy when I'm serving in the
Senate I grew up just south of
Philadelphia had a couple children in
Pennsylvania I mean these are fairy
tales but even The Inquirer who's not
been a big Ally of mine is saying enough
fetterman start talking about real
issues stop hiding in your house the Joe
Biden program is not the right thing for
democracy come out and talk about real
issues but frankly Laura he never has he
didn't talk about real issues in his own
primary he didn't leave his house that
much to campaign people thought he was
lazy I don't know what it is but he
doesn't like to go out and meet people
and actually answer questions and I'll
give you a good example I was I mean you
know it was Eerie earlier today I got
the Fraternal Order of Police
endorsement which I'm very uh
appreciative of and it was unanimous and
I'll tell you why it was unanimous I
think there was a capital police
African-American officer there and she
said she had never in her career been as
disrespected she said John Federman and
makes you feel like what's under your
shoe when you walk out of a dog park and
she says when this lieutenant governor
is treating you poorly like that
everyone else treats you poorly let's
look at Philadelphia the city that I
that I live in you know we have the
highest murder rate ever ever
known record keeping and yet we've got
one third of all the prisoners he wants
to release he wants to decriminalize
drugs he doesn't want any life sentences
no matter what you've done wrong he's
hiding behind his radical views at home
let's get him out talk to the people
admit what you're really representing
and let the Pennsylvania public decide
who to vote for
well there's no there's no doubt about
it I'm just gonna I'm gonna say it this
way a vote for fetterman is a vote to
keep these disastrous policies that have
destroyed the energy industry in
Pennsylvania
jacked up gas and food prices and given
a rubber stamp to to Chuck Schumer
that's what he is he's the costume
doesn't work it's tedious and everyone's
I think is beginning to see through it
Dr Oz We're watching this very closely
we appreciate you thank you